Welcome to Udacity's Full Stack
Web Developer Nanodegree.
My name is Michael Wales, I've been
lucky enough to be a professional web
developer for over 16 years.
It's a job that I love and
I'm passionate about.
I joined Udacity to help people like you
launch themselves into a career that is
fun, exciting and
in a field that is endlessly growing.
By completing Udacity's full
stack web developer nanodegree,
you will have the qualifications you
need to start or advance your career as
a professional web developer with
the portfolio of projects to prove it.
For example, you'll build a movie
website to share your favorite movie
trailers with your friends.
You'll build a database driven
application to store and
analyze the results of a tournament.
You'll build an item catalog website
that includes authentication and
allows users to update the content.
You'll build a massively scalable
API that powers a mobile conference
application.
And finally, you'll turn a bear
bones Linux server into a secure and
efficient web server
your applications demand.
>> With the help of
our industry partners,
we designed these projects
to showcase the skills and
technologies companies are looking for
when hiring full stock web developers.
Our team here at Udacity is excited to
help you develop the expertise you need
to build these projects.
Before you get started, we'll help you
figure out if this nanodegree is a good
fit for you right now.
Then once you're in the program, you'll
be supported by your student community
and by Udacity's coaches and
instructors.
We'll be here to deepen your learning,
offer project feedback, and
help you develop professionally.
We look forward to
working with you soon and
we can't wait to see where
your nanodegree takes you.